Beijing rolled out the red carpet for
Prime Minister Michael mishustan the
highest ranking Kremlin official to
visit China since Russia invaded Ukraine
Beijing is strengthening ties with
Moscow despite criticism from the West
meeting President Xi Jinping on
Wednesday mishustan said relations had
reached an unprecedented High
two sides signed agreements to deepen
Corporation in Trade Services
Agriculture and sports
on Tuesday Miss Houston opened a
business Forum in Shanghai attended by
about 500 Russian delegates trade
between the two soared by 30 in 2022 Ms
Houston says it could reach 200 billion
dollars this year
with plans to increase Russian exports
of green and energy and manufacture more
Chinese cars in Russia Moscow is
increasingly using the UN and sells oil
and gas to Beijing at a bargain price
analysts say Russia is more dependent on
China than ever before it's definitely
fair to say that it's an unequal
partnership for sure um you know it's
important to remember that even prior to
the Ukraine Invasion the Russian economy
was orders of magnitude smaller than the
Chinese economy and now that a lot of
it's uh it's been shut out of Western
markets uh China has become an
increasingly important buyer for for
Russian energy but while there are
benefits there are also liabilities the
Friendship has damaged beijing's
reputation in Europe and China's special
Envoy is now working to repair it this
past week leeway has visited Ukraine
Poland and France officials say his tour
is a mission of Peace though Kiev says
it won't accept any ceasefire that
involves losing territory to Russia
the visit follows the G7 Summit in Japan
where Western leaders repeated
condemnation of Russia's Invasion
something Beijing has refused to do
saying it's neutral in the conflict
Xi Jinping declared a No Limits
partnership with Russia before the war
he needs Putin's support in what he's
described as an ideological struggle
with the U.S and its allies but this
partnership does have limits China's
economy depends on the west and it must
be careful to comply with International
sanctions Katrina you Al Jazeera Beijing